[Music]
many believe that Gears of War has what
it takes
they would be most successful video game
franchises of all time
since day one my brother and I just know
that strong bond just like DOM and
Marcus dude playing Gears of War has
changed me because it brought me into a
world of looking at games as more than
just games people that are playing these
games now grew up playing these games
and they've seen Marcus and Baird and
goes through all of the trials and
tribulations that they have and now
there's this new generation and the fans
get to grow with the characters
we're basically minutes away before
going on stage in front of millions of
people and introduce the world to here's
five I don't think people really give
gears it's due for the influence its had
on modern video games we were playing a
game but you're also watching a movie
here's families is like the most
passionate base I've ever been exposed
to they're so warm and welcoming and
they love this game and they're
passionate about it when you meet them
in person it's almost as if everybody
knew each other to begin with whether
you're in it for the story or the
characters or the camaraderie it's just
constantly giving fans something to care
about their cow a cow you can tell what
a game has a little bit imagining is
there's something about it that pulls
you in that makes you go oh that is so
cool I've never wanted a game to come
out this badly there's nothing else like
that and the amazing team at the
Coalition is working hard to bring you
our most ambitious Gears of War title
yet Gears five
[Applause]
legitimate gels it was trying not tear
up try not to tear up like every knee is
sore spectrum oh I mean I think we've
got a fair bunch of them here to be
honest oh now it's come to the time the
show that you've all been waiting for a
first look pictures five vote yes I am
absolutely loving are they here now is
the world premiere trailer four years
five horde mode
[Applause]
[Applause]
from the shadows like a lion on the run
I'm coming laughs I'm
for the [ __ ]
[Music]
now you see me now you don't
my
right
oh yeah watching every mom doing dog
humping secure the death step fishing
hearts the boy getting closer
[Music]
[Music]
battle play four days early with Xbox
game pass Altima
[Music]
[Applause]
keep laughing I'm never gonna stop
clapping just totally late right
discriminators expert well well in that
we saw gameplay Ultimates and sorry
grain but we're great badass-looking
drives me but before we bring the
coalition to the stage Xboxes catalina
Macedo caught up with a team to take a
deeper look into court for Gears 5
I'm Catarina and I'm here at the
coalition studio today I'll be talking
with studio head Rod Fergusson and
multiplayer design director Ryan flavin
about the upcoming years v horde mode
just being here at the studio you can
really feel the excitement and the
passion that went into this game and
this mode so let's go check it out we
always talk about coop as cake and not I
seen that the coop is central to what it
is to be gears and so I feel like horde
is sort of a really large expression of
that with five player coop everything
started with gears to horde it was
lightning in a bottle it was you know
what people look back on as the defining
defensive game mode through all games it
was the idea that you were going to be
doing this as an endurance run as a
three-hour epic experience and a mode
like without any cutscenes without any
you know character development without
any story had to hold people's attention
for three hours
and we here's five what we feel that
we've done really is almost the complete
realization of what gears to set out to
be the big thing for us now is this idea
of ultimate so there's basically
characters used to be just defined by
the weapons they carried and your we
were all the same you just looked kind
of different and you know gives you all
could carry the same weapons but now
every character has its own ultimate
ability his own special ability you can
bring to the game that changes how you
play you could look over and see Kate
trying to gather power and you know that
she has an ability that to turn herself
invisible so you don't need to worry if
she gets in a tough fight there's also a
really big thing called taps now which
are these energy geysers that show up
are on the map because generally when
she find it in or he would like lock in
on a particular place and you would
defend from that place for the entire 50
waves now in order to get as much power
as possible to get as strong as possible
you actually have to move and expand
your base to go and capture those energy
taps and every ten waves once you beat
that boss a new energy tap appears and
you have to go and capture it so it's
really changed the dynamic where now
it's much more aggressive and it was in
the past for the first time your
character will start with all the cards
that they've already equipped but they
will then increase the power of those
cards and increase the power of their
core abilities over the course of the
game and that progression is
unresearched
you can do it again the next game and
this means that every game feels fresh
if you can try it a different
combination of perks that work with your
cards in a specific way seeing people
make a certain bill like here's a cake
build I use these cards with these perks
and and here's a dell build and I think
it'll be really exciting to see them mix
and match and see these different play
styles come together one of the things
that we've done that is subtle but super
important is that whenever you pick up
power which is the currency and can
hoard that power gets equally
distributed amongst everyone and that
means that if you see some power on the
ground everyone will want you to pick it
up
and then we've added stuff to give more
information to the players and things
like health bars / bosses and
mini-bosses and so there's little
feedback mechanisms and it allows you to
play differently because now I can see
that the mini boss is on very little
health so I know like I'm gonna get
aggressive because I know I can do it or
I can see oh there's level lot so I'm
gonna hold back to take characters and
push them even further we've added
jackpot as a playable character inside
hoard it's one of the most pivotal roles
on the battlefield Jack could fly
anywhere on the map maybe move really
quickly faster than anybody else he can
heal people repair things really he's
the jack-of-all-trades and you really
want him to be your best buddy over time
we're gonna add new characters and with
each character we add the meta will
change we will have different
combinations of strengths will have
different team compositions that will be
beneficial to certain kinds of players
every time we add a new character and
every time we add a new map what we hope
to see is the Horde community come
together to explore this space and show
us what the best combination of
characters is
[Music]
and so that idea of finding five people
who know how to balance the classes and
how to balance the characters and know
what the objective is and what you're
trying to do and everybody's playing
together in lockstep with each other
there's nothing more special than having
that alignment and in succeeding on I
call it's really by far from our point
of view the most intense engaging
action-oriented
fierce epic defensive load there is in
video games I really like that record
creates the dependency where you work
together as a team and you can be
successful kind of you know lone wolf in
it but not as successful as coming
together you know it's sort of our motto
for the studio we always say if you want
to go fast go alone but if you want to
go far go together and that's true for
Horde as well it's been so exciting to
be here today as the gear Spence is ears
one I cannot wait to get my hands on the
new horde mode and all the new features
if you're a game best ultimate
subscriber you can get ears 5 on
September 6 for everyone else the game
will be available on September 10th
[Music]
that words an incredible first wave is
okay is bimodal now plug a huge founder
pause for rutberg than a right even for
joining us here in like can you tell a
bit more about those cuz they look
amazing yeah The Ultimates each one of
them is unique to the character they're
really something that we see like both
defines them as well as creates a really
great relationship with the team
we've got Kate going invisible we've got
JD that could call in like a giant
artillery strike we've got del who can
summon trackers to help him out each one
of them you're gonna have to find the
the character that works for you and
works best for the team and it's and
their per character so it's not on a
parole thing so even though if you have
multiple engineers each engineer each
different character will have their own
ultimate so you can still mix and match
that's gonna be really nice I think
that's one of the great things I'm
excited about all those different play
styles that you can find kind of suit
your personal playstyle yeah that's one
of the things like we were talking about
it like one of the it's this is probably
the deepest toured we've ever done even
though it's still super accessible but
that the deepness allows you to go in
and set your skills what character you
want we'll give you your ultimate but
also that when you're collecting that
power you're not just feeding the
engineer liking gears for you're
basically collecting power to get the
engineer to build now you have perks
which you can go in and say oh I want to
do more damage I want to do more
headshots I want more ammo I want more
health so you catch your plane you have
this in-game progression that you can
change who you are in the moment and so
you have out of game progression in the
cards and you have in game four a
progression in the perks mattress Theory
crafting with that like I forget this
combination it's what you may say yeah
yeah because I'm but talk about
accessibility one of the things you talk
to us about in Vancouver is all the
different difficulty settings players
are gonna have access to yeah it's a
little bit more about that yeah I mean
one of the big things for us is
realizing that gears was gonna be a day
in dating game pass and all the game
pass was that we realize we're gonna
have a bunch of people maybe you've
never played the game before yeah so we
wanted to create a lot more
accessibility to the game and whether
that's accessibility features in terms
of how you control we have things like
single stick control ability turn a
camera shake and all those sorts of
things but even also from the point of
Jack was created from a perspective of
being accessible because maybe some
people but the idea of like going into
cover and pixel hunting shooting and all
those sorts of things like Jack doesn't
have that Jack floats above cover Jack
does area-of-effect sit back so if
somebody who's just new to the game they
can come in as a support bot and they
can help you they can heal you they can
keep you like you know buffed up they
can go and repair stuff they can pick up
weapons for you so they don't have to be
like while bouncing shotgunning that can
actually just be part of and we really
wanted to make them like a really
critical part of the team it wasn't just
about having like a support class that
sort of stands at the back and does
nothing jack is super critical we really
wanted to envision him as your best
buddy like your best friend like each of
the other classes I want yes now there's
so much demand for Jack when you're
playing him you just constantly feed
like you're feeding all these little
bernie is a crazy ultimate like yes it's
height we call it hi jack yeah I care
about funds in the race and so hi jack
is basically shoots a dart into an enemy
and then takes control of so it
possesses identity so if you have you
know something coming at you like a
scion with a boom shot you can take it
over and out Jack player becomes a sign
with a boom shot and can help destroy
the enemy it does everyone's just gonna
want to be Jack's best friend good
there's a sonic white of glory for Betty
unfortunately that in mind what sort of
sets coordinating gears fight apart from
the previous iterations you're obviously
told us a lot already but yeah I mean
that's probably there's really a bunch
of big differences when is the ultimate
the other is this power tap that Ryan
and the team came up with which is
probably you bet yeah so like that we've
added the power taps that you saw on the
video which really add an element of
territory control we wanted to make
Gears 5 not only the deepest but also
provide other ways to be successful by
not just building fortifications
so the power taps appear every like 10
waves after the you kill a boss and that
means that you have to really understand
whether you want to move your base or
just let it go
they're optional however they do provide
a ton of power to power up your perks to
buy fortifications with so if you decide
to leave them alone it's at your own
peril however if you're ambitious and
your team knows what they're doing they
can slowly expand their base to control
more territory for more
yeah lots of options well now from
software to hardware got it cuz I'm good
anyway let's take a closer look as
something gives fans everywhere a
shorter salivate over its the limited
edition Gears 5 Xbox one X we recently
caught up with some of the minds behind
the design take a look I always want
ears to stand unique in the way that it
pushes on innovation and storytelling in
the hardware and that was the hard part
for us it's like okay what are we doing
with this what story are we telling how
we make it feel premium and that was the
biggest challenge when we were designing
the console we imagined that Kate was
walking across a frozen lake like the
one that you see in the e3 trailer and
something in the ice catches our eye and
she leans over and clears a patch of
snow and she sees a reflection of the
omen looking back at her in reality
their electronics in this console
there's no way we can put you know an
omen two inches inside of it so we had
to create an optical illusion that would
make it look like there was an omen
trapped underneath the ice we were able
to express the idea by laser etching
these ice cracks around the omen we've
never laser etched that much before I
mean the laser etching is all over the
console the the ice is cracking all over
the console theming the controller after
Kate Diaz was really a natural because
she's like the main character in the
game and she is exploring this Arctic
environment she wears an Arctic armor
which is new in the game which was
exciting to us whatever we were going to
work with in terms of accessories and
hardware we wanted to family with what
the console was going to look like
so we're able to work with Seagate on
some amazing 5 terabytes 2 terabyte
drives that look basically mini versions
of the console there's gonna look
perfect right next to it and we work
with razor on like keyboard and mouse
it's one of the first I think wireless
keyboard and mice for the console and
they get a whole family of products that
all fit together so working with rod is
an awesome experience every time he
understands how to point out the
meaningful moments that we can really
pick up on as industrial designers and
bring into the physical world we always
walk away from these design
collaborations with him feeling like
this product is so authentic like it
couldn't be any more authentic because
it's it's so closely tied to all of our
conversations with him
[Applause]
and we're back we've got to write about
how amazing is that console look I want
this so much not second grass the team
the design in that because that is
incredible and a hard drive but next but
that's not all we've got to talk about
so you've also got some news with our
friends over at valve yes tell us a bit
about that so the first time we're
coming to steam and today you can start
pre-ordering today for there's five on
Steam n they'll be cross-play so it's
good news the day rod rod please yes
plans to do with Halo so we talked about
the Ultimate Edition we talked about
being ultimate game paths we really
didn't really talk about what you get
for doing that so we're really happy to
announce that we're actually putting in
two characters from Halo Reach you're
gonna be coming to Gears of War so we
have cat in the meal they're coming and
they have their own roles will be
playable in Horde and escape and vs. and
you're gonna have their own Ultimates
you want to talk about the two ultimate
yeah so we really tried to be very
authentic to hello while still making it
kind of integrate into the gears world
so we've got the drop shield on on a
meal and that like we've you know we've
looked at reach and we wanted to make
something that halo fans would really
recognized as a drop shield and then
we've got the hologram on cat and it's
you know she's the subterfuge experts
and so she's gonna distract the the
enemy well then everybody else goes into
something else and that's the same
actors so we went out after coming after
a decade or brought him back into the
booth and we recorded and you know what
we've got a video that shows off exactly
that check it out
looks amazing
[Music]
after baiting grumpy
by special
[Music]
but just look amazing every time I've
seen I'd call that natural and it goes
beyond the characters as you can see
they got custom weapon skins custom
banner custom mark like all the
customization stuff that we have with it
as well as really cool yeah it's I
cannot wait to kind of like get in get
my hands on with it but we've been
talking partnerships yeah and you've
also got a clothing partnership which
I've lived in like III yeah I mean we've
worked with the folks at bathing ape to
create their they have a line that we've
you've got a tees up at e3 with our blue
yeah and you can see we're doing there's
an in-game as well so that blue is
coming in to inside the game that you
can wear as part of a case of sort of
you know the camo outfit and then we
actually do a physical line which is
going to be in red now our red camera
which is gonna be for sale at the ape
stores and that yeah it looks really
really cool and that's the different
styles and what you saw from the blue at
e3 and then different designs and so I
was intending to bring it with me today
but you know customs was fun so although
I do enjoy the Canadian uniform you're
wearing for me so I appreciate that it's
very much appreciated themed already you
need a bigger beard though I'm gonna go
lumbersexual you need a bigger beard it
doesn't grow also the street wear love
with me is keen on what's in store for
gays and bathing ape how can I get my
hands on the hood because it's it's not
it's not here no it's not it's no they
have their store like in New York in LA
yeah again it'll be they'll be limited
on the Xbox gear store and then again
you can get it in game alright amazing
she's gotta wear matching hoodies in
game broad he might be done off stage
but you're going straight to the games
gone opening night broadcast can you
tell us what's going on oh yeah I'm food
so you know since he three we've heard a
lot of people asking about like well
what about the campaign you know
we talked about we're gonna talk about
escape we're gonna talk vs. we're gonna
talk horde which we were doing people
our notebook campaign so I'm going over
to talk to Jeff Keely and we're gonna
put a new story trailer all real all
real-time cinematics is all from the
story from the game itself and I'm gonna
talk a little more about gears I'm so
excited I've just got a skip on the hick
we just get a huge round of applause to
the gears it looks like what Ryan I
thank you so much for joining us III
think it's